the fellowship of the ring goes through
a lot during the lord of the rings
but after the ring is finally destroyed
each member finally gets the ending they
deserve
from the wisest of wizards to the
humblest of hobbits
these are the fellowship's character
endings ranked
for a wizard who always seems to find
himself in the thick of it gandalf's
story
ends surprisingly enough with more of a
whimper than a bang
by the time of the lord of the rings
gandalf has been pottering around middle
earth for around 2 000 years
he gets particularly busy towards the
end of the third age
at which point he helps to drive the
necromancer out of murkwood
sets the quest of arabor in motion and
sees the one ring on his way to mount
doom once all the action dies down and
aragorn becomes king however
gandalf enters a kind of early
retirement in the book version of the
return of the king he travels with the
four hobbit adventurers back debris and
then splits off to visit the mysterious
tom bombadil two years later he hooks
back up with the hobbits at the grey
havens
where he boards a ship with galadriel
elrond
frodo and bilbo and heads into the west
this is because valinor the land across
the sea was gandalf's original home
where he had lived as the wise spirit
ohloren before being incarnated as a
wizard presumably upon his return
gandalf shed his elderly body
and settled back into a quiet
comfortable and well deserved
life i will not say do not weep
for not all tears
at the end of the lord of the rings mary
initially lives with pippin and his
homeland of buckland
a hobbit colony on the edge of the shire
eventually he inherits the title of
master of bucklin from his father
and becomes known as mariadoc the
magnificent evidently impressed with the
nominal leader of buckland
aragorn makes mary a counselor of his
northern kingdom
mary also plays the part of the
historian
traveling around middle earth gathering
information and writing down as much
as he can this includes a manuscript on
pipeweed called herblore of the shire a
portion of which can be found in the
prologue
of the fellowship of the ring much of
his writing
also ends up finding its way into the
red book of westmarch
the manuscript that bilbo frodo and sam
are seen working on in the lord of the
rings mary also remains a writer of ron
a position that he had been granted
after swearing allegiance to theoden
during the war
of the ring he stays aomir's faithful
servant from afar for decades until
long after he becomes an old man he
travels with pippin down to rohan where
he witnesses the passing of the king
mary then continues on to gondor where
he spends the remaining years of his
life
after aragorn and pippin pass on mary's
body is laid to rest beside his comrades
during the war of the ring pippin swears
fealty to denethor
and like mary and rohan he retains his
status as a knight of gondor long after
the war ends
this makes him one of aragorn's loyal
followers and the king rewards him for
his service by making him an official
counselor of the north kingdom
as far as his life in the shire goes
pippin inherits his father's title of
thana the shire and becomes the leader
of the tooks he also gets married
settles down and has a son
of his own while not a historian like
mary pippen does begin collating a huge
library where he collects various
manuscripts that later become pivotal
in maintaining the legacy of the war of
the ring
at the ripe old age of 94 pippin retires
from his role as thane and joins his
lifelong friend
mary as they head south to visit eomer
from there the pair head to gondor
where pippin eventually dies as well
bringing an
end to a long and happy life
though a royal prince of the woodland
realm of merkwood
an immortal elf and a member of the
fellowship of the ring
lego lost backstory is never fully
fleshed out by j.r.r tolkien himself
when it comes to the elves later life
flow there is a bit more information to
be found
and like most of the elves of middle
earth it's a sad and slow
state of affairs sooner or later most of
the elves heed the call to return to
valinor
but legolas doesn't leave straight away
first he and gimbly go on a number of
adventures throughout middle earth the
pair of heroes visit the glittering
caves eglaron
at helms deep as well as the ants and
fangorn forest
not one to sit still for long soon after
arriving back in mirkwood
legolas gathers up some of his people
and heads back to gondor
there he settles in the garden-like land
of ethylene which becomes the fairest
country
in all the westlands even here though
legolas is unable to find
peace and after aragorn dies he builds a
ship and sets sail for the blessed realm
with none other than gimli by his side
gimli is a sturdy young dwarf during the
war of the ring
coming in at a youthful 140 years old
this gives him plenty of life to live
after the war and he puts it to good use
first he embarks with lego loss on their
trip through fangorn forest and the
glittering caves
and it's in that second place that gimli
finds his true calling
at one point during the battle of helm's
deep kimley was forced into the caves
and he found himself smitten by their
jaw-dropping beauty
his description of them is so compelling
that it's precisely what convinces lego
loss to suggest that they visit the
caves themselves
gimli is so taken with her natural
beauty that he eventually returns there
with other dwarves and sets up a colony
becoming the lord of the glittering
caves in the process
after aragorn dies it's recorded that
gimli is actually granted permission to
travel with lego loss to the undying
lands seeing the opportunity to meet the
lady galadriel again
he accepts and becomes the only dwarf to
ever journey
into the west by a great measure
frodo beggan suffered the most out of
all the members of the fellowship
while the others took on armies of orcs
trolls and ringwraiths frodo
endured a devastating battle with the
one ring itself
the ring is imbued with the power of the
dark lord sauron and frodo's key victory
is the simple fact that he's
actually able to get to mount doom in
the first place
without having claimed the ring for
himself along the way
unfortunately frodo's scars endure long
after the ring is destroyed
the wounds he endured by the witch
king's blade and shelob's stinger
trouble him for many years
with frodo falling deathly ill on every
anniversary of each stabbing
it's been four years to the day since
we're the top sat
it's never really healed after the war
of the ring frodo spent some time
writing down his story
and then plagued by the memories of
these old wounds set sail
for the undying lance in search of a
place to finally receive the healing and
rest he needs
whether he dies soon after getting there
or lives a long
happy life in the immortal country frodo
finally finds peace
at the end of his long journey
boromir is the heir of the steward of
gondor and one of the finest warriors in
the fellowship
he arrives in rivendell initially
seeking answers to a prophetic dream
attends the council of elron and before
he knows it
finds himself joining the ranks of the
fellowship of the ring
throughout their journey boromir serves
as a crucial protector for the
fellowship
particularly during their battle and the
minds of moria
after that however things begin to turn
and boromir soon gives in to the lure
of the one ring eventually he tries to
take it from frodo
who narrowly escapes and heads off
toward mordor with sam by his side
while boromir's actions technically lead
to the breaking of the fellowship the
hero
ultimately gets a redemptive ending one
that is nothing less
than truly heroic he quickly repents his
misdeeds and arrives back on the scene
and time to find mary and pippen being
carried off by a pack of pursuing urukai
oromir defends the hobbits bravely but
is nonetheless overwhelmed and fatally
wounded by the retreating orcs
in the end the son of gondor dies in the
company of aragorn
his friend and king fly you fools
since he appears in two separate
physical forms over the course of the
lord of the rings it's probably worth
bringing up gandalf again
especially since at the end of his life
as gandalf the grey
the fellowship's wizard literally goes
down in flames
after millennia spent orchestrating the
resistance to sauron gandolf the grey
finds himself swept up
in the events of the word the ring never
one to shrink from a challenge he
identifies the one ring since frodo on
his way
uncovers saruman's treachery and then
becomes hands down the most powerful
member
of the fellowship of the ring as gandalf
leads the company
south towards mordor they eventually
enter moria
soon enough the fellowship is attacked
by goblins
trolls and of course a balrog gandalf
makes his stand against the balrog
on the bridge of kazadoom and after a
brief battle plunges along with it into
the deaths below
the pair fall to the deepest darkest
pits of the mountains
then climb up the endless stair and
there at the mountain's peak
gandalf finally defeats his enemy the
grey wizard then
succumbs to his wounds before being sent
back to middle earth
as gandalf the white of all the
characters in the lord of the rings
samwise gamji is the one who finds true
peace
after the end of the war after he bids
his master farewell at the grey havens
sam returns home and inherits bag end
where he settles down with his wife
rosie with whom he has 13 children among
these children
are four sons named mary pippin frodo
and bilbo sam is also elected as the
mayor of the shire for seven consecutive
seven-year terms
aragorn subsequently makes sam a
counselor of the north kingdom
along with mary and pippen and his
daughter eleanor becomes queen arwen's
maid of honor
after over 60 years of marriage rosie
passes away
and much like bilbo long before samwise
decides that the time has come for one
last journey
he leaves bag end and heads to the grey
havens where he becomes the last of the
ring bearers to board a ship and head
over the sea
to the undying lands after the war of
the ring
aragorn becomes the king of the reunited
kingdoms of
gondor and arnor aragorn rules for an
impressive 120 years at which point his
son inherits the throne
but aragorn doesn't die in order for
this to happen
not in a traditional sense at least in
the appendix of the return of the king
it's explained that he felt the approach
of old age
and knew that the span of his life days
was drawing to an end
bequeathing his crown and scepter to his
son
aragorn goes to a prepared place of rest
and lies down to surrender his life
willingly
a distraught arwen protest but aragorn
insists that his time has come
he adds take counsel with yourself
beloved and ask whether you would indeed
have me wait until i with her
and rail for my high seat unmanned and
witless
though heartbroken arwen lets her
husband go aragorn's final words
are and sorrow we must go but not in
despair
behold we are not bound forever to the
circles of the world
and beyond them is more than memory
farewell
and with that the long life of gondor's
greatest king
finally comes to an end check out one of
our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about the
lord of the rings are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]